olalala le cligno oui
si vous pouvez oublier ce qu'il se passe
ce serait cool les amis je me suis
souvenu ya pas longtemps que moi quand
j'étais jeune j'avais envie de raconter
des trucs alors j'avais rien à raconter
parce que j'avais une vie vraiment
basique de mecs de 15 ans on peut pas
être une gaufre quand on a 15 ans je me
suis souvenu ya pas longtemps que
j'avais créé une chaîne secondaire à
l'époque jane qui s'appelle squeeze n 6
la dernière vidéo date d'il ya cinq ans
mon gars ça c'est une chaîne active
alors je me souviens que j'avais créé
cette chaîne pour faire ce que je
faisais pas faire sur ma chaîne
principale à savoir des petits blogs qui
n'avait aucun intérêt et tester des
trucs des fois voilà ce m'amuser alors
aujourd'hui on va regarder les vidéos de
cette chaîne là j'ai complètement oublié
chaque vidéo c'est incroyable je n'ai
aucun souvenir de ce que j'ai pu faire
cette chaîne et je vois les miniatures
je vous avoue et ça me fait un peu peur
quoi déjà je me souviens il ya un truc
que je me souviens par contre j'avoue
cette image regardez bien oui c'est ce
que vous croyez vous avez 15 ans vous
voulez faire une photo un peu style est
trop c'est une [ __ ] d'allogènes et
metella vous dans la gueule et fait ce
geste avec votre main là vous avez un
maximum de style première vidéo de la
chaîne couverture de la chaîne
alors c'est quoi cette chaîne squeeze
dit nous on va savoir sur tout le monde
si ce coup ci on se joue aujourd'hui
pour la présentation demain back up
chanel et à tort j'étais plus stocks que
maintenant ça fait mal
regardez le biceps brooks qui s'est
passé entre temps là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans mon cas cheveux claude plein de
vidéos dans la vraie vie et aussi des
fois des ans plus tard il a grêlé non
mon jeu et aussi à la quelques moments
jeu et quelques trucs et filles qui me
sont arrivées dans les jeux ces drôles
-j'adore avec ja j'ai tellement de
remarques à faire ça se voit tellement
que j'ai pas du tout à l'aise quand je
fais des respirations et de regard dans
le vide et juste après je fais à
mouvement avec mon corps pour montrer
non non je suis à l'aise regardé et je
suis sûr que le freeze là ce n'est même
pas prévu c'est juste chez elle plus
quoi dire et du coup je m'étais bloqués
comme un coup genre vrai réflexe nul
bref quoiqu'il en soit je vais commencer
par présenter parce qu'on a peut-être
certains d'entre vous ou certaines qui
ne savent pas qui c'est vrai ça c'est
vrai prénom lucas jeux d'eau nîmes
internet squeeze cet homme fait des
vidéos sur internet qui sont plutôt
hilarante
c'est pour ça qu'il a un peu de succès
ouais j'avais déjà de lego je mets mes
déjà assez flou je voulais faire c'était
comme dans un jeu vidéo quand tu choisis
ton perso qui tourne sur lui-même mais
en vrai je marchais vraiment quoi
j'étais vraiment en train de tourner sur
moi même dans ma chambre chose du clan 2
fait environ 1 m 68 e âge mec j'ai pris
2 cm en 6 ans à ce moment de la vidéo ce
que vous y réalise qu'il a été petit
toute sa vie qui l'attend de grandir
depuis près de six ans et que ce n'est
jamais arrivé
il remet alors en question toute sa vie
sa carrière ses amis son chien savary
ramener en tout cas j'ai claude rey
beaucoup plus de vidéos que sur ma
chaîne principale car il n'y aura pas de
montage à faire ou presque ce sera des
vidéos brut prise avec mon super
téléphone portable et les profits mais
tu vas la fermer trois ventes l2
abonnez vous alors est-ce que je les
fais la vidéo tous les deux jours où est
ce que j'ai fait une antoine daniel 12
octobre 12 octobre 12 octobre 12 octobre
j'ai mis quatre vidéos d'un show non pas
13 14 mai gros on n'a jamais vu un gars
syrie d'union 15 mai oui alors qu en
squeeze se met au fight chaude c'est
quoi les faillites chaude j'ai oublié
bonjour à j'ai eu mon heure call of duty
1 est ce que laisse que j'étais bon bah
[Musique]
c'est tellement le vieux game you tube
ça s'est tellement le vieux gamme
youtube
tu sais
[Musique]
ces nuages étaient déjà pour rio j'ai vu
qu'au début en fait je pleurais juste
des petits clips de jeux de mots jeux
vidéo quoi des clips où je me trouvais
stylet regard de jeu modifier les
couleurs comme un bâtard donc je voulais
faire comme les gens style et de
l'époque comme diablo x9 artec est tout
sauf que moi j'étais nul à une vidéo
regardez regardez ya six ans merci à
tous mes abonnés ouais c'est vrai qu'à
six ans je pensais déjà à vous je
pensais pas à consulter un bescherelle
par contre ça c'est clair et net c'est
tout le monde sait squeeze la petite
vidéo très courte pour remercier
naissante cette abonnée parce que c'est
un salon énorme non vraiment c'est
vraiment je trouve ça vraiment sympa de
votre part pour un maintien mais en 2011
ça gratte déjà des jeunes sur les vidéos
à 1100 a rien inventé rien relevé
vendeurs de tapis c'est qui c'est lui le
double cliquer sur j'aime pour cette
blague doubleclick manque pas un clic
simple double-clic gros gaillard bug ou
revas pont pour tous vos commentaires
vos conseils vos idées vos mails vos
fins tout ça quoi
c'est drôle parce que je me souviens
quand j'avais 107 abonnés y en avait 35
c'étaient des amis et les 78
il m'envoyait vraiment pas de mails où
il mettait vraiment très de commentaires
sur les vidéos georges fait le gros
mytho au genre je reçois trop d'amour et
tous merci je suis touchée alors qu'en
vrai je recevais vraiment rien j'étais
obligée d un truc aux mondieux le
premier blog une maison très design je
crois que la qualité est là chier on va
pouvoir regarder et on se retrouve tout
redécouvrir la nuque à trois 2 1 go let
go
je n'ai plus d'oreilles c'est bon mais
menace se faisait marrer ça la soul et
[Musique]
regarder tout ce qui est bien chez moi
il vous avait pas car vos parents sont
moins riches que les miens c'est
horrible on va je trouve je découvrais
pour la première fois le frigo américain
de ceux qui envoient de la glace et tout
est du coup j'ai trouvé ça ou fait du
coup j'avais fait une vidéo
il en fallait peu pour faire une vidéo à
l'époque mais je sois que ça m'amusait
beaucoup à cette machine a donc il ya
vraiment y'a vraiment j'ai des glaçons
que devant un verre on est d'accord et
je rigole énormément oh [ __ ] la caméra
hd y as you tout le monde si squeeze
aujourd'hui pour une nouvelle vidéo chez
mon père ça ça c'est le long couloir tu
mon père dans lequel il fut chef sylvain
mille fois parce que j'avais extrêmement
peur je voulais juste vous dire que en
fait il se trouve que la caméra hd elle
est dans la poche place des messieurs
non plus sérieusement mon père a accepté
de me la donner dès maintenant
donc vous pouvez tous dire merci le
padre de tout cas parce qu'ils ont
commencé papa je vais pouvoir avoir 10
millions d'abonnés rejouerez vivent de
ce que j'aime
merci papa voilà hélas dams et messieurs
j'ai une technique pour percer dans rien
que celui-ci bien vous avez cliqué
maintenant c'est tout oui ne fait pas ça
déjà à l'époque l'influencé mal la
jeunesse c'est bien bravo l'udc a fait
des petits trous comme ça et ça fait pas
ah oui c max chaque midi c'est comme ça
moi que je fais donc ouais d'accord le
blog c'est juste dire j'ai une caméra hd
je mets un plan micro ondes on est bien
d'accord je vais aller tourner la vidéo
que je mettrai en ligne lorsque j'aurai
10000 abonnés la vidéo de présentation
donc j'aime casser le cul encore à faire
des vidéos alors que la chante d'une
dissertation là le gars il se plaint il
se plaint le gars est fait des vidéos il
se plaint déjà quoi excusez moi si j'ai
une voix bizarre c'est parce que je vais
vous dire que je suis malade ne me dis
pas que je vais chanter la chanson je
suis malade
j'espère vraiment pas je dis que je suis
un peu bd c'est horrible d'être malade à
ce stade là d'abonnés c'est chiant
d'être malade tout court lucazeau bats
les couilles thomas bonnin de mes blogs
je faisais que de me plaindre c'est vrai
depuis tout à l'heure je me plains gros
c'est dingue achats jamais fut ensuite
en attendant les 10000 à tous et là on
enchaîne là là on enchaîne donc les
10000 ça fait ça fait six vidéos que
j'en parle quoi gens c'est vraiment une
obsession c'était maladif pour garder le
style
le gars il sait qu'il est proche dit
emilie pense qu'à ça en fait j'ai
également parlé des 10000 parce que je
me souviens que je m'étais donné de fou
pour les 10000 abonnés j'avais fait un
truc de présentation est en fait à la
fin je dansais tu avais le choix entre
plusieurs vidéos il y avait six vidéos
gros est mec je m'étais donné ce bon
passage fait que d'en parler c'est que
j'en avais chier je crois alléluia au
[ __ ] qu'est ce que c'est pas cela un
peu de joie là c'est à dire que je vais
chez le coiffeur minutes vous comprenez
pourquoi j'ai eu des problèmes
capillaires pendant si longtemps
j'allais chez le coiffeur une fois tous
les cinq mois mon gars étaient si rares
que quand j allais je faisais une vidéo
avant pour dire à quel point j'étais
heureux vous rendez compte de ça alors
maintenant je vais toutes les semaines
ok je prends ma vengeance sur la ville
un clin du bien beau de couper de raser
la toux donc dans un instant je vois un
petit montage vidéo vous verrez que les
cheveux coupés on veut on peut voir j'ai
intérêt à sur un montage 3 2
je remercie le quoi faire et regarder
bon ça c'est même que d'habitude on va
pas se mentir même si la saf un truc
chez nous mais mec c'est normal j'ai
jamais chez le coiffeur
tu as vu la cour qui me fait comme jv go
si bien grave mais rembourse moi si tu
regarde cette vidéo t'as pas honte une
entrée un pic à bas on veut la voir
du coup monté squeeze
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lucas quand tu écoute de la musique fort
quitte ambiance énormément ce qui se
passe dans ta tête tu ne peux pas leur
transmettre à la caméra on voit juste un
petit enfant pas très stylé qui dansent
mal sur une musique pas ouf
des gens ne vont pas ressentir ce que tu
ressens hockey parce que ma mère va me
nuque et ça je le dis pas ça bah non
[Musique]
une petite exclu pour vous au bas c'est
quoi les scrutins ça doit être un truc
incroyable sachez qu'un bosser sur les
vidéos en ce moment et j'ai même changé
une lumière pour que ça fasse une
lumière plus agréable dans la vidéo non
c'est faux comme quand tu es à dota ce
besoin de dire tout ce qui me passe par
la tête tu vois comment gradient on
arrive à se canaliser et là vraiment dès
que j'ai un micro idée qui me passe par
la tête et oblige et de la dire tout de
suite je viens de me souvenir de ce à
quoi tu as besoin de tout excès reese et
que tu vois un truc tu dois te dire au
toit fermé en tout cas jeté comme ça
c'était journée dungy cd musique que je
faisais avec fait durer l'époque à voilà
les laisse anciens reconnaîtront c'est
génial c'était mes potes du lycée un
groupe qui me cadrer à ce moment là on
s'est beaucoup de trucs ensemble avec
antoine et florent il s'appelait ses
rangs un moyen de se taper des bonnes
barres ensemble et de créer des trucs en
même temps et en visitant content de ça
je trouve qu'on entend c'est d'être au
bon souvenir quoi les chansons sans eux
j'aurais pas pu les faire par exemple
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance d'avoir un
entourage à l'époque de potes qui
comprenait ce que je faisais et qu'ils
joignent aux délires et ça les faisait
qui fait isolé et il était par moddy's
braqué il trouve c'est la honte
c'était tout l'inversé quoi donc c'était
vraiment sympa il a un peu saoulé mon
pote il est un peu saoul et je le fais
chier c'est bien là non comme ça plus et
donc ça ça avait donné donc c'est déjà
de bêtisiers de journée d'un gi qui
était le premier gros boss de mme hachem
onana la première au plus tard tu
stomisés vos manettes pour pas cher mais
qu'est ce qui se passe je vous parle de
cette chaîne donne simplement parce que
le directeur est sympa c'était y avait
un gars qui avait une bois et a contacté
m à 12 15 ans sur net en lui disant est
ce qu'on fait c'est génial c'est
vraiment top me suis même avait mis la
pression pour que cette vidéo quoi c'est
parce que les prix sont bas je vois là
là
vous imaginez je fais ça maintenant vous
agir discours comme ça maintenant là
pour qu'ils aient en échange le soleil
m'avait juste customiser une manette
pour voir ma première hop et du coup en
gros j'ai touché 20 euros c'est bien à
propos du cas bonjour tout le monde
s'est tu
aujourd'hui je suis pas là pour vous
parler d'un sujet quelconque par exemple
géologie sait pas trop à ça pas toi je
suis là pour vous parler de la vidéo
j'aime call of que j'ai dû supprimer car
si vous voulez il ya une séquence que
pour un oui je me souviens de cette
histoire bon je vous la simple puisque
l'aca 4 minutes 20 je vous la fait en 10
secondes
en gros on avait fait un deuxième clip
après jamais d'un guide que je ne vous
montrez est le deuxième club avait
trouvé un marché sapé j'aime call of
sauf qu'à un moment on tapait un numéro
et tout le monde s'est amusé à appeler
le gars est du coup le gars m'a appelé
moi pour me dire elle supprime ta vidéo
parce que tu m'appelles c'est relou et
donc j'avais dû la supprimer foot et
numéro l art met en ligne et j'étais
dégoûté voilà y avait but ce pack 3 qui
l'avait commentée hockey et ça ce n'est
pas rien de mon petit coeur en [ __ ]
j'ai fait un court métrage un jour gros
j'ai fait un court métrage
un jour c'est parti est ce que c'est
mais bollywood et on va voir entrer
quelqu'un tu prennes ton max non c'est
bon ah ouais ouais j'aime faire
l'impasse
[Musique]
non je me tais tu veux dire c'était la
grl dedans mais ces axes
franchement si vous voulez je vous vends
les droits de ce court métrage pour
votre prochaine pub ya aucun problème
contactez moi vous me customiser une
manette xbox et je vous lâche la vidéo
surprise pour fait ok si j'avais fait
chacun
ah oui j'étais chez les parents du
gouffre est à côté de reims pendant deux
jours j'ai filmé plein de petits trucs
que j'avais fait une petite vidéo
surprise c'est vraiment ce que tu veux
quand tu veux pécho une fille
normalement vraiment mais j'ai fait pour
mon ami c'est très bizarre
donc j'ai vraiment film est un mec torse
nu pendant 10 minutes
faire du piano pour en faire une compil
et la m sont hachées de secondaire
[Musique]
franchement hugo à table à zurich ou des
trucs
ouais après y'a rien dit ou fait si
j'avais fait dans les t-shirts avec mon
frère à l'époque sur spreadshirt ces
t-shirts là il n'existe plus d'ailleurs
certains vers chez nous c'est collector
vraiment non c'est faux ça pue mais
c'est sympa c'est après une fois que je
bosse avec mon frère du coup c'était à
cinq ans alors j'avais 17 ans quoi est
il était grave chaud et oui ma vie mais
il m'avait fait confiance sur ce truc là
et ça lui avait fait aussi un peu
d'argent pour lui puisqu'il avait bossé
dur là-dessus c'est vrai on peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui c'est lui qu'a fait mal
ou trop café l'image de la chaîne la
bannière de la chaîne
et là on est en train de bosser sur
d'autres trucs j'adore et je les aime
très fort florent et la dernière vidéo
de la chaîne c'était au moment de la
sortie du dernier album de daft punk bon
ben voilà il ya un sujet il ya un thème
moi je parle d'un truc que j'aime là
c'est bien non là c'est bien là et on y
est alors au [ __ ] merde au le dogue
il a mis du serpentin sur sa terrasse
boyaux et allogènes des amis c'est la
fin de cette vidéo sur ce petit tour de
ma chaîne secondaire n'hésitez pas à
aimer la vidéo si elle vous a plu [ __ ]
mais c'est fou cette gen secondaire
j'avais oublié ce que je raconte est ce
que je faisais pourquoi je les fais j'ai
tout oublié
c'est génial en tout cas ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que on commence tous par
faire des trucs un peu floue un peu
bizarre on n'est pas très doué dans ce
qu'on fait et c'est pareil pour tous les
milieux je pense un gain qui commença à
dessiner il est pas bon d ça un gars qui
ont ce faire la musique bat il est à
chier au début c'est normal c'est comme
ça dans tous les milieux créatifs et
j'ai juste envie de vous demander d'être
indulgents que vous voyez quelqu'un
qu'on est encore à ce stade de sa
carrière qui est pas très à l'aise qui
sait pas trop ce qui fait qu'ils
racontent pas grand-chose bah c'est pas
grave ça c'est rien de le beh et soyons
cool avec avec les gens qui en sont au
début de leur truc justement au compteur
en cours à journée devant leur de la
force en fait c'est impossible d'arriver
sur youtube et de tout de suite marché à
mort gagner je sais pas combien
d'abonnés faire des vidéos génial non
faut passer par une phase où tu te
cherches où tu apprends à faire ce que
tu as envie de faire ou tu prends une
direction et je trouve qu'on oublie
qu'il ya cette phrase qui et qui
pourtant est très importante donc voilà
je vous fais des bisous je quitte cette
vidéo en étant très ému je vous dis à
bientôt pour un truc un peu plus drôle
même si je sais tu es drôle quand même
en vrai je vais me boire un petit café
natsu leader tellement bien je suis
obligé de filmer au type la vidéo comme
on l'a commencée tiens regardez il est
tellement bien élevé
allez m'aider
oui mais des bruits d
et
[Musique]